Yeah,
the problem with the ICJ is effective at
certain things,
what it tends to do,
kind of the bread and butter would be at
a territorial dispute about where the
border is and our river between two
countries and when you kind of need in
that situation is just a neutral
arbiter.
You need someone to come in and for
domestic political reasons,
maybe you don't want to give up this
little island that somebody else's
claiming and the ICJ is very good at
sort of just drawing a line and making a
decision that seems neutral and
acceptable to both sides.
The problem with the ICJ is when it
wades into more controversial issues.
So recently it had a decision about the
wall and in Israel,
um,
it had a decision about nuclear weapons
a few years ago,
uh,
and it tends to have a hard time with
those decisions.
Uh,
and so for that reason it's not,
um,
it's not as effective as it lacks some
of the enforcement powers we might want.
You might compare the World Trade
Organization's Court,
the Appellate Body,
so that court is considered to be more
effective in part because it has at its
disposal enforcement measures,
uh,
and it's got a pretty good compliance
record.
So when it hands down a ruling and it
says to even the United States,
you're violating the law.
Usually those countries comply.
So,
um,
so not all international courts are the
same.
Um,
and I'd say the ICJ is,
uh,
is good at certain things,
not everything
question because the US does have a
unique role in a world and we are far
and away the most powerful military
power and we are very much viewed as a
country that's going to win when there's
something happening in genocide or
folding.
Um,
we have the capacity to act.
We don't always actually have the
capacity to act and people do look to us
to play that role.
So we do have some unique concerns that
other countries don't necessarily have.
That said the ICC is widely accepted
around the world and I think it would go
a long way.
I think many of the concerns against the
ICC,
the idea that there's going to be a
rogue prosecutor who will go after
American service or that we needed,
you know,
Congress passed this law,
The Hague invasion act.
So if any American ends up in the break
of the ICC,
we're authorized to go in and,
you know,
invade the Netherlands and get them out.
I think those kinds of fantasies are,
are really unfounded.
And so far the ICC has been very
cautious and I think it's again,
a,
uh,
mostly symbolic issue for us to join
because,
uh,
I don't see a,
the [inaudible] principle is that if a
country tries in good faith,
its own soldiers,
the won't step in and we have a well
functioning military justice system.
So,
so I don't imagine the ICC,
a ruling over Americans,
but I think symbolically it'd be hugely
important and particularly after the
Bush administration's last seven plus
years of being seen as rejectionist of
every international initiative,
uh,
pulling out of the ABM treaty.
I'm on signing the international
criminal courtroom statute.
I'm denigrating the Kyoto Protocol.
We've lost so much goodwill.
And remember,
after World War II,
we were really the architects of this
international system.
We've lost so much of that that I think
these symbolic,
uh,
steps like signing the Rome statute
would go a long way towards restoring
our,
I think,
our traditional image in the world,
which is a touch
at this point.